so kevin kelly uh has another question
um
i think so he he asks describe
the most optimistic neo-biological
future that you can imagine
in a century from now um
you know we can imagine that uh public
health um is going to require
all of our genomes to be sequenced um
that
um
we'll be there we'll be there long
before that but i think the um
you know us making that as an assumption
that um
that that so much of our genetic
information is going to become part of
the health care system
and that uh it will also include
some of the advantages that can be that
can be put out there are there
um what what do you imagine uh as some
of the greatest benefits
um that you that you want um
you know as as your own self or as a as
a mother of other children
um you know what are what are uh what
are some of your thoughts on the future
of this
so um i imagine a future where
um uh first of all genetically inherited
diseases have been
eliminated if we have a disease
we quickly know how to treat it because
we sequenced you at birth we understand
what your
risk factors are um and you know we have
rapid vaccine and um we have first of
all rapid testing we have
rapid therapeutic development and we
have um
uh prediction models so uh
so we can basically address disease um
i imagine that we have um
converted from industrial manufacturing
from extracted economies to
biomanufacturing and to growing things
with living systems
so we as a result of that have been able
to clean up our planet
um we are living in a continuum
uh with all the other uh biological
systems on the planet
and so um we are no longer
extracting and polluting but
harnessing and shepherding and um
and growing things uh in a way that
puts us in a more sustainable position
i mean to me that is that's the vision